battle the doctor set my parents down
and said my life was fragile perspective
is the game
i guarantee the name just put your head
down do the work and everything will
change
sympathy helping fields yeah that's what
i wanted be a patient hello
[Music]
what's good tfam uh wednesday
august 26th uh happy to be here i am
garyvee
and this is t with garyvee uh let's get
into it
let's uh i'm 9 45 today so um
a little bit shorter of an episode
dustin you well
yep good
internet uh i think i'm locked
in a charizard
hollow shadowless first edition psa 10.
i don't even want to know how much that
costs
so pretty excited about that all right
let's keep rock and rolling
jen good to see you scott bogart thanks
for joining us let's give some shout
outs before we get into it
uh i see linkedin i see twitch i see
sebastian i see matt
taylor you're my guy as well charles
hatfield what's good rob what's good
kash bp great to see you um
share squad let's get some share squads
going and also
today uh on wine text
crazy crazy rose offer if you drink rose
in your home
period if you buy rose you have to go to
winetext.com right now
and sign up if you've not signed up for
wine tax this is a service i created for
my dad's business
it is crazy please leave a comment right
now if you are part of wine tax or
if you live in the u.s and you're not in
illinois or texas
there's a couple other states and you're
going to sign up now tell me because
today literally the best rose deal we've
ever offered
um and september's become the number one
month of rose consumption
um and so just uh i see the
i see the love for wine text in the
comments i really appreciate it and
share this link right now let's get some
people to enjoy us
um jenny thank you for being part of
wine text today is a huge day
huge huge day i'm fired up about it all
right let's get into it
gary good morning welcome to the poke
cave
nick i didn't even know you were the
first guest and what an what if
you heard what i said to uh oh the first
edition sharks are psa ps810
hollow shadowless that's the king
there's only 121 of them in the world or
something like that
just yeah just about one that's the
range how are you nick like what your
world must be
going nuts oh it's insane it's
absolutely insane and
as soon as i heard you talking about
pokemon and seeing you post about it i
was like
oh my gosh this guy's already awesome
how could he get even cooler
dude it's so cool to see you jumping
into pokemon everybody is so excited
about it so
you know what's funny the sports card
stuff comes supernatural to me i know
everything about sports pokemon
my my life with that was i already
started my kind of business career when
that craze happened but
i have aj who's 11 years younger than me
and he was right in pocket
middle school when it came out i
remember aj had
like pneumonia or like was real sick
and i convinced my dad one day after
work to go down to the sports card store
and i was out of sports cards at that
point
but i knew it existed down the street
and i knew aj was on pokemon and
we bought him a box of like the you know
the first
shadowless and um yeah i'll just never
forget how happy he was
like just going crazy and and
it's just an incredible ip and
i i really think that cards in general
are gonna
be looked upon the same way that
contemporary art
is looked upon so i bought the charizard
hollow
because i look at it like a jackson
pollock or andy warhol
um and i i think people are grossly
underestimating
how much more room this has over the
next decade yup i agree 100
and actually that you jumped right into
one of my questions was i actually had
you quoted up here
as saying um after your vacationary
thing
you uh three years ago
yeah it literally the the top five
percent the massive transformation
uh just like you said with contemporary
art so that was actually i was going to
jump
into that and ask you to elaborate on a
little bit because that really
that got me thinking as soon as i saw
that post um i'm like wow that's
you you were you were away for a week
and you really kind of i feel like you
kind of thought about it a little bit
more i had some more thoughts
thought about a little more i thought
about it pretty much the whole time i
was very downtown
vacation and like was had been thinking
for three you know this has been a
three-year journey for me
um you know again pokemon clarity for
the audience and for you is
no question the place that uh um i'm
least knowledgeable about but my inner
circle
lou tyler aj they're they're all like
deeply deeply into it dustin
dustin and like and like jason like a
lot of people like but those three
who i talk to the most on a daily basis
are very very very deep
it's the so here's how i look at it
i think the people are very confused
because they look everybody you talk to
and i'm sure you're living through this
when you talk about this and it's
starting to happen it's hitting the
mainstream
a lot more than it did two years ago and
everyone's original like
thoughtful smart people are like but
gary like like
this has been around for a while like
why now you know why now
or or or the bigger issue people looked
at sneakers in 1994
as things you wore on your feet people
did not look at them
as things that people would sell for 25
000
a pair things change over time
you know like things come along like
people oh
watches didn't start off as something
one would collect
there was there was a very weird
conversation at some point in history
i'm undereducated on this
where somebody's like these are
collectible items and
everybody in the town square laughed at
her or him
and so you know to me i look at
who what's the makeup of the 40
to 60 year old the 35 to 55 year old
currently in the world and what is she
and he
gonna do for the next 40 years that's
different than what their parents did
i have zero interest
in buying you know a three million
dollar painting
could couldn't be less interested
you're about to have to go on ebay at
2am and hunt for cards
i love that process but i'm talking
about forget about me because if you
focus on a
focus group of one you always lose like
this had nothing to do with me i've
loved cards my whole life i
i've been public since 2006 with one
since you've been 12. you started going
around with the with the yeah
but i've been doing public content from
2006
to 2000 uh i've been really two years
now 2018 i went 12 years and the only
time i would talk about sports cards
was as a context point to my career
right so when i started talking about it
two years ago i was like you need to get
into this
and the amount of money that
my community has made because they
bought leukodontics at thirty five
dollars or fifty dollars
and now are selling them at two thousand
i mean the emails and dms i get
are just incredible but the reason i'm
bringing that up is for 12 years i had
the chance to talk about it
but i didn't because it wasn't happening
three years ago i saw the early
indications
of believing that cards were about to
explode in value
specifically i thought basketball
because of its overall popularity and
its global reach
the internet ebay and stockx
infrastructure
soccer proper football and you know to
me
proper football basketball
and pokemon are the clear
most interesting places i also get very
interesting in wrestling
vintage and vintage basketball
but but i think pokemon
there's a lot of people that the the the
ip
the passion around pokemon is much
bigger than people realize
much better i i think if you've surveyed
most people about
where pokemon sits versus star wars they
would lose that bet
they don't understand how big it is most
people with star wars like
it's real real real big it also is
gender neutral in a lot of ways so much
great female collecting action in
pokemon absolutely
excuse uh has a higher percentage which
i think is much needed because
women make things always better dudes
with dudes always
come up with so like to me i i just
i i think that there's an incredible
shift and that a lot of people
call it a hundred thousand wealthy
people
and you've got to understand how this
all works a hundred thousand
wealthy people 39 42
would rather have a bill russell
1957 tops psa 9 a
you know a charizard right
um yeah hollow first edition psa 9
with a walter payton 76 tops rookie
with a you know it's not as valuable but
a ken griffey jr psa 10
upper deck because that's their
childhood and they're gonna i think
whoever builds
the best in-home case to display
25 of your top cards as a piece of
furniture
is about to build a 50 million dollar
business
yeah so i think that this the wealthy
are going to express their wealth
because that always happens
through sports and pokemon and
alternative cards
graded in home that will trickle down
and then when you start seeing you know
these cards go from fifteen a hundred
thousand dollars a piece to a million
dollars a piece it will all
trickle down right yeah
you've got a whole generation of people
that want to be entrepreneurs
nothing nothing will teach people that
are watching right now 15
16 13 19 more than learning how to buy
and flip a piece of cardboard and
learning how to merchandise it
hold when they're held when to sell
buying and selling
trading you know living that
kind of like raw like human trait of
trading
you know rocks for sheep sheep you know
it's in us it's what we do and i think
pokemon sits at the
nostalgic it's so nostalgic for so many
people i mean
going back for myself i grew up with it
you know as it it popped off in 1999
2000 and i just want i want megan to
megan i i apologize that you i want to
just address a comment i love you but
the card thing is taking you over money
money money invest invest
your message of happiness is confused
megan i apologize and
and maybe it's just my sheer excitement
i'll try to be
much more clear with this it's not how i
see it at all megan i
i think that listen i'm a businessman
and my message is absolutely
about happiness but the you know
happiness can be put through a lot of
different highways one could be talking
about it through a family dynamic
through a craft dynamic you know my lane
is
entrepreneurship and business i
i megan i don't know if you uh what you
know when you say this
card thing is taking over what you're
seeing is deep happiness in me megan i'm
actually
likely gonna leave a lot of money on the
table because i'm
focusing so much on my happiness right
now that i'm not doing other things for
my other businesses
that would make me more money i'm really
really sorry that that's what you
um you know what what you're getting for
me and more importantly meg and i
appreciate the hearts
i will do a better job i think i'm so in
the excitement
i'll be honest with you i think there's
a whole
slew of people that will have so much
more happiness buying and selling
pokemon cards than being a lawyer
and like i actually think this whole
conversation is actually about happiness
we're talking about
cardboard with pictures on it being
a a commerce capability i can't believe
that millions of people are about to
turn their hobby
into their profession which is actually
going to lead to dramatically greater
happiness
than them dragging themselves to the
jobs they hate
so again you're right megan i'm
definitely like trying to
help people understand the economics
behind it
but megan what you need to understand is
that almost everybody dismisses how
significant this can be i don't think
people understand
that even if they're average there's a
very substantial chance if they don't
gamble
and poker you can go into this like
people gamble they buy packs
and i think they're valuable but if
you're going to open it up go ahead
please
anyway megan that's my i just want to
make sure there's no confusion
i always speak in parallel of like
financial stability
and and happiness and doing what you
love
and i think megan you know this and
that's why you set the hearts i want
people to make 130 a year selling
pokemon and leave their 230 000
a year job i want people to leave you
know to leave their 47 thousand dollar a
year
teaching job and make 39 000 a year
flipping you know
garbage pail kids because they'll be if
they'll be happier doing that than
teaching
i'd rather them stay teaching if they
don't or what i'm really excited about
is for a lot of people and this is where
it really gets fun for me man
for a lot of people here if they study
for 15 to 20 hours
because if they just go to ebay and they
buy a qualifier psa which has a stain on
it they'll get rip you can get ripped
off fast
in pokemon especially because there's so
many variations of the first series and
a million things
but meg the thing that i'm most
passionate about is that
hundreds of thousands of people that are
gonna watch this video over the next
couple weeks
so many people are gonna make an extra
thousand dollars a month that is gonna
allow them to take their family down to
the jersey shore
and have a trip while the government's
not sending us subsidized checks anymore
so yes
i am i am um you know
excited about the commerce stuff it's
not about the
the money money money part is a
collateral of the happiness
that also will help so many families
when we go into this real recession
because we're not sending people free
money
anymore yeah anyway let's go deeper it's
the happiness
of it because if if just for a little
bit of history on me
um i tried the college thing i you know
dropped out two three times
and it wasn't for me it didn't work for
me i couldn't sit there and i just
i just couldn't do it so i jumped into
uh different things i actually started
going to garage sales yard sales
nine ten years ago before a lot of
people were doing it and people were
doing it but you could literally go to
any garage sale and there was hits every
single one yeah
so i did that for a while but in the
back of uh
what i was doing was the office jobs the
nine to fives the construction work and
those were the things that
i wanted to get away from to make myself
happier
and i took all the money that i'd made
from the garage sales and yard sales
turned it into other
business ventures and built on from
there and about five years ago like that
was the hustle right i mean that's
that's what you preach right so about
five years ago i got back into pokemon
solely based off of that nostalgia and
the happiness and that's what helped it
grow
genuine passion happiness and excitement
out of it which
uh you could just you could see it in
people i mean i could see you knew the
passion just
going on and talking about it so from
there
is where i grew it and about a year ago
i started my youtube channel not even a
year ago eight months ago i started my
youtube channel and decided to go full
time
with pokemon and trading cards um so
that's what i do now on youtube pokerev
and
one of the biggest things that we do is
and strive for is just to have fun
but also with that be able to teach
people
and and help them learn about you know
what should i buy what should i sell um
you know the market collecting and
things like that and just i mean just
for example like a first edition
jungle booster box um a lot of people
ask about the first series of pokemon
you know where to
start and i try to help people go in the
right direction with pokemon so like you
said
if somebody wants to make an extra
thousand dollars a month or a week
they have that opportunity right here
right now and it's happening right now
and not even just the vintage it's
definitely happening i just want to make
sure
everybody who's like wait a minute
what's going on here because they follow
me from all the other stuff and they are
not following me in this world
you have to get really educated people
right you'll agree with me right like
people
i mean saturday morning i will go and i
will we would talk about pokemon for
four hours straight
and i'm sure you've seen so many people
you know cry out of like crap i got
excited i went on ebay i bought this
and then i realized it wasn't the right
one or it i didn't understand what a psa
qualifier was or
i'm sure you see a lot of that right
right and so and the reason i bring that
up everybody is like
this is not like a gold rush or things
that nature there's a real significant
moment
and this will be a a moment two four
seven years and then like everything
it will then just like pokemon just a
sports car it'll
there will be a direction that may
happen in four years that may happen in
four months that may happen in seven
years i don't know but
clearly things are going this way but
where you will really get hurt right now
even though it's easy and every time you
buy a card it goes up a week later
or a box or things that nature is if
you're undereducated and you think
you're buying something
when you're not yeah that's the one
there's the yellow and red cheeks
pikachu in the first you know like you
can you've got to be educated there's
there's a lot of variations
you have any questions um the one
question that you hit on with the
contemporary art
um i did have one thing i was hoping you
could help me cross off my bucket list
if you have a minute uh i always
wanted to say that i opened up a booster
pack with garyvee so
i got a couple right here let's go let's
do it
just so you don't have to get in here i
know this will fire you up like this
all right so this is hidden fates right
this is a modern set that was released
last year
inside of here the biggest hit you can
get is the charizard the shiny charizard
cell and the psa 10 is going for about
1500
and this is just a modern pack that you
could pick up at the store like you
could go to target walmart and pick up
this pack
so not anymore right
there's the reprint coming but um
[Music]
i mean if we pull the charizard here i
don't even know so
basically we'll go through here when we
get to the rare
come on can we get a hit let's get ahead
we get a hit with garyvee
let's get a hit let's get hit let's get
hit
not in that one i got all right we gotta
get it one more one more
one more one more for the road
let's go let's get it one hit
and what we do is in the chat we bring
the luck so guys throw in some
electronics yes
charmander right speed you got that
first edition
shadows charmander right yeah and i also
have a shiny hidden fates one
oh nice come on
hollow hollow even better than nothing
better than nothing listen opening up
packs is such a thrill
get educated follow this channel we'll
talk soon brother take care of yourself
appreciate it thanks
i wish you well keep pushing me too
this little eevee
oh my god man i can't believe i'm here
talking to you right now
i'm nervous a sec how are you doing very
good my friend where are you from
uh originally from vancouver bc uh
visiting my family
right now but i currently live in
montreal quebec
man i just want to say thank you so much
i've been watching your content for
almost three years now and honestly man
you've just changed my life like
you've been putting positivity and
perspective hard work and hustle
in my ear every single day and because
of you
i found my passion i do videography and
content creation
and actually from the woman that i love
because of you so honestly man i just
hearts out to you and just say i
appreciate you so much
i love that thank you so much thank you
kyler what can i answer for you brother
yeah man like uh like i said so my name
is kyler i'm a videographer
at content creator i do this full time
for a company like i said in montreal
quebec
called simply php and earlier on this
year
before covet i started actually a show
called the making a show which is a
podcast
youtube show dedicated to helping people
get started through the process of
making it kind of to
what you did for me you know a lot of
the advice you're giving me was just
start
just go ahead and do it and i picked up
a camera fell in love with it
learned everything to do with it and
then made my career
out of it right so i wanted to pay that
forward and let people know that hey
you can start this process and you can
make it happen
i love that yeah thank you man thank you
and so i'm trying to
document this journey of me becoming
this kind of creative entrepreneur
yep um so my question is around
documenting over creating
so how do i know i'm bringing value
while i'm documenting
and and kind of learning at the same
time because to be honest very
like i find it hard to know what to say
sometimes
while i'm documenting well documenting
if you're thinking about what you're
saying then you're thinking about
creating
documenting is just documenting
do you have the humility to show the
process
is the real question kyler
documenting you becoming this person
means predominantly that you're showing
your failures
but most people want to show the
highlights which is super scary
which is super scary but ironically
why people will love you yeah so
like from a practical standpoint let's
say i messed up on a client shoot or
something like showing those kind of
like and you and you may listen i don't
want you to lose your job
so you have you have to be careful um
but yes yes in a way that doesn't become
detrimental to you and your family
or something you learned like like i
learn
things like all the time that like yeah
i remember like
seven years ago me really grasping
ebitda
which was something that like a business
person should have really understood
you know 10 years earlier than that like
that would have been a great thing to
share
got it i i think so i i guess getting
over it too
like hearing you say it i get it and
then getting over it too like practicing
it every single day and
and putting myself out there as uh the
next kind of
hurdle yeah it's you know like
it's you have to you have to be okay
with the wins and the losses
and it's if you're documenting
if you're really really really really
talking about your journey then make a
journey
everybody sucks bro
yeah bro everybody sucks
yeah like don't put anybody on a
pedestal
not me not your dad not your mom that
not
you know mark cuban uh margaret thatcher
like i don't know
like whatever you know not anybody just
like
show it
behind the scenes content me editing
till midnight at night and
documenting is documenting i gotta grab
this dustin can you take over
kyler documenting is documenting
not editing highlights let's move the
dust
thanks gary thanks kyler thanks man
oh my god thank you so much i appreciate
you you got it
all right so i usually like to have a
little bit of a
alert that this is going to happen you
know like the karate guys that mentally
prepare
so i break the brick but i'm not
mentally prepared for this right now
so i'm just gonna bust out some of these
cards again um so
i got these japanese cards
japanese a little harder to determine
but trying to do some research
let's keep going cool cool
gary what's up what's good my man how
are you
man i'm pumped i'm uh been trying to get
on your show since
when did you start this in march uh
yeah your team kicks ass and i
appreciate you but
give you a little context i'm sort of
trying to figure out professionally
you've talked about you know the grind
and the dirt and
being soft and i
i wonder if if being soft
holds you back and what you can do to
overcome it because
you know i've been in real estate my
whole career um
i'm in austin texas sort of new here
five years ago was working crazy hours
crazy money like you've talked about
very lucrative but just a [ __ ] life no
fun with the kids the family
the wife at the time that didn't fly so
i changed things up when the wife
checked out on it
and to save my relationship with my kids
so i've sort of gone
to just basic stuff i'm a realtor sort
of like your sister
i followed her yesterday so hopefully we
blew her up collab
and uh and that type of thing and now
i'm in a situation where
i'm doing the realtor thing it's a grind
as hell i'll still do the grind and
stuff like that but through the tough
times i've really had to lean on my
family i feel like it's like the honey
hole i know i can go to
and they're super supportive but what do
you do when you get to a point like now
like i want to pull the trigger
make a shift in real estate not
something huge
but is that when you say supportive on
the family who are you referring to and
are we talking about emotionally or
financially
both the financial part will hold you
back
the emotional part's awesome yeah the
financial part if you feel like you can
get money from mom dad brothers i don't
know who you're referring to
like that's a problem
like that is a fundamental problem
when when one does not stand on their
own two feet
they are always unbelievably vulnerable
and more importantly
they subconsciously do not have the
leverage with that human being
and that human being is able to kind of
dictate that person's life
yeah it gives them a little extra
influence for sure
a ton of extra influence yeah people
don't want to bite the hand that feeds
them
and so it puts you in an you're you're
unhappy about it here it's why you're
asking this question which is amazing
i'm so proud of you first of all for
being able to say that out loud because
that's not something
many would want to admit i would argue
that the far majority of people over the
age of 25
who take money from a family member to
live their life
90 of them keep that quiet so the fact
that you're even able to put that out
there
and the fact that you kind of like just
painted the picture it's funny where my
chemicals are going right now i'm pumped
because
that means you're on the edge you're
gonna do it
yeah it's a lot harder to tell a million
people right now
in the world over the next six months a
million people watch this
that you do that than it is to stop
doing it
and make a jump right right
no i think it's your your content about
not really giving a [ __ ] what people
think about me
has just woken me up and i think it
needs to wake a lot of people up i mean
i'm
exposing myself because i don't want to
be held back i want happiness
i wanna i'm i'm so uncomfortably i don't
know if the goosebumps come through like
proud of you right now chris you're
literally it's really fun for me because
people come on this show and they're
very different places
of the process to get to the upswing
sometimes they're on the upswing um
like you're like my favorites are this
one
when the person is literally an inch
away from like getting dramatically
happier
yeah i'm pumped for it man
bro all you have to do is stop taking it
literally it's as simple as that
and this is for the millions of people
that are watching over the next
15 years of this video the second you
stop
taking money from somebody all you have
to do is live more humbly
every person can live a little more
humble do not let your parents your
brother your sister
sometimes your child have that leverage
on you
yeah it's huge it's huge bro because
what you know chris
is it like yeah it
makes you not go it paralyzes you
that's the thing like right now it's not
slinging it killing and doe in the door
it's and i'm still
sort of paralyzed it's like why now
listen
first of all i love that you took
assessment and you said wait a minute
i don't want to do p pattern recognition
so let me create
real meaningful time and depth of my
children that's just a remarkably smart
move
well yeah it was like you know i can't
control what another adult wants to bail
but i'm going to save my relationship
and by the way the more you look at it
as
did she bail or did you create scenarios
that
you know like it's really like even
making whether you guys were 50 50 or
even if it was more on you
the second you even change in your mind
the word bail
the more you're gonna win right right
no you gotta own your [ __ ] own your [ __ ]
bro
accountability own your [ __ ] you know
what's going
the reason the world is so on tilt right
now is everybody in america just wants
to blame
somebody else right right
like it's so it's so not fun to look
yourself in the mirror
and to blame other people for me it it
feels good
in the micro of course it feels amazing
in the microwave and then in the macro
when you gotta go to sleep at night and
wake up it [ __ ] sucks
correct which is why i tried the reverse
eat [ __ ] in the micro and [ __ ] love
the macro
right right amen the real game's in your
own head with yourself
life is you with you everybody's playing
it as if it's you with them
i don't even know them i don't even see
them
and i mean and you know this pro and con
gary you're so humble people let me i'm
like because i don't believe in the
cheering
i don't think i'm special i don't think
i'm a genius
i don't think i'm great i don't i think
i'm nice
i like it but like guess what my mom's
just as great and so are a million other
people
like i like it's just circumstances
but what that equally does brother is it
like
i could give two shits of the
businessmen and women that make more
that have more for the guy or gal that
ends up buying the new york jets that's
not me i'm [ __ ] happy
with you congratulations now win me a
super bowl like
i don't care like that
i just want to be happy back to the
earlier comment where
the very lovely young lady i already
forgot the name megan i think
was like gary you're losing your way
with this card saying i'm like no no no
no no no
i love this it's the passion i'm finding
my way
yeah i'm finding my way i can make a lot
i can raise i can be spending this time
right now raising a huge
hedge fund and make 40 trillion times
more money and buy the jets
no no i want to be happy i want to look
for
walter payton rookie cards at you know
11 30 p.m last night because vintage
football is like maybe the next thing
like that no no no no
no the passion's deep my brother's like
at target all
walmart he's killing it i go to target
walmart i don't know
[ __ ] about it i'm buying cards like
the question is do you want i think what
you need to do is take a step back and
think about like what do you like yeah
is it music is it food is it movies
like to me i like like this was my whole
pat like
this is the every single day from 1986
to 1993
this is all i thought about not girls
not school
not this so this is what i love so first
fun what you know think back to junior
high high school you
you know outside of like if you're
normal
girls they're like the kind of like boys
you know but like
what do you like well you said a couple
weeks ago
if it was a lot that you had to start a
business
or you went to jail that hit me huge
that was badass
because it's so true that really puts
you in perspective like holy [ __ ] what
would i do
if it when you don't change chase the
paper like my man
daniel j just said with the money when
you don't chase it
and you chase like desperately wanting
to wake up and be fi
let me give you an example this is a big
insight for me
i have woken up more excited for work
every single day over the last four
months and i
asked myself why and then i looked at my
calendar it's because i'm doing a lot
more business development
every day more than half my day now is
potential new client potential client
groups of clients marketing for the now
new clients clients so i'm on the
offense when i looked at my calendar for
the last two years
it was defense operations operations
operations so i
i promoted mark yudkin who was my
general counsel
who's been with me even before
vaynermedia doing my
he was my lawyer when i bought twitter
and facebook and tumblr
he's now being promoted to coo i'm still
very operational but i'm going to try to
move more to him so i can do more things
that i like
i'm in a better mood when i'm business
developing
right right yeah
it's just a nuance in real estate i love
real estate but i like
more the investment side the roi side
then
so real quick i would tell you that you
like
transacting on like
you like the invest the real estate
development side more than a
transactional one-off
home thing well the more
dollars or because you think there's
more strategy in
more strategy more brain activity i
agree so to me
i do think you need to look at like what
are your hobbies
i i work back way back like high school
you what did you [ __ ] with
high school food skiing tennis cards
like help me i mean high school i was
southern california i love the beach
love the water the ocean
love surfing oh yeah i mean if i could
get in salt water every day i'd be
chris you need to think that you need to
think about surfing culture
yeah like maybe you start a [ __ ] west
coast
brand like vance like there's like you
gotta go into that
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
entrepreneurial that's in my head that i
[ __ ] with all the time but it's about
pulling the trigger
that holds me back because i got what
are you scared of going backwards if you
fail financially and having to go
to the wedding well i mean when i grew
up my dad was a hot mess
alcoholic didn't produce didn't bring
income
drama cops domestic the whole thing and
so
if i'm not producing income
generating money financially i feel like
i'm
good with me what time do you go to
sleep
around tanish great what time do you
wake up
uh well for your show i got up at five
but
usually about six good so you get a nice
eight which is amazing
talk to me about 8 pm to 10 pm
you know i've thought about this because
i've literally
shut off work at six and then
i have something to eat and i'm like i
just wanna
there's nothing that wants yeah i just
that's okay this is going back to i veg
by going on ebay for three hours
and finding some rare card that nobody
sees yet yeah
yeah i want you to veg from 7 30
to 10 30. notice what i'm i'm playing a
little bit here
on the building of your surfing podcast
or your surfing tick tock or your
linkedin like i'm telling you right now
brother
this is what i wrote crushing about and
your first book is always the biggest
insight to who you actually are
yeah it's right there your 7 30 to 10 30
is the most interesting thing to me in
the world i know
that you can find something you can veg
to that will
produce income for you at 29 months in
and that's what you can be doing while
you're bringing an income from
8 am to 6 pm period and the story i
believe it i've seen it 100 000 times
yeah amen
and and chris start nine different
things start a surfing [ __ ] content
thing
start you know do that for four months
yeah you change like you see where i'm
going like what
all nine things and do you do all nine
things if you're not
like if you're so pumped about five of
them do you really
[ __ ] with the other four no i probably
go with those five and just see what
happens
and one of the five may pop so much
you're like [ __ ] it this is actually
working people
[ __ ] with me here i don't need the other
four
cool that's the real deal
7 30 to 10 30. write that down put it
right now and then just look at it every
day 7 30.
every day ask yourself what
if i could start a business or i have to
start a business
okay i'm going to do this surfing thing
i'm going to do the surfing thing i love
if i could be in water all day
basically i want you to interview every
great surfer if you dm'd
all 800 great surfers and said i'm
starting a surfing podcast will you do
an interview with me
three will say yes chris yeah and that's
a good use of 7 30 to 10 30 six days in
a row
the dm for sure
slater's that kind of guy he'll just say
yes no he's a good dude
great dude and i know some guys in those
circles for sure
then that makes me even want to punch
myself in the face more because you're
[ __ ] ready
and then guess what four episodes in
you're like [ __ ] i'm bad at interviewing
people this is stupid
yeah and great so next it's like
you've always wanted to design a shirt
you might be the next ocean pacific
for all the old cats you know what i'm
talking about or jam shorts
chris listen to me you can do this it's
7 30 to 10 30. you do it for two years
something starts happening and then it
actually becomes your eight to six
that would be badass yeah no no it's
real brother it's called the internet
yeah shut it no i did your flip game
even though i didn't know what the [ __ ]
i was doing and flip some cards some
boxes
made 100 bucks and i was like damn it's
real
it's supe bro i'm so scared for my
reputation to not be good
that i'll never say anything that i
don't already know works
it just doesn't happen i knew that cards
were gonna pop for
six months and would spend an hour every
night
or when i was traveling like just
quadruple checking because i knew i was
going to get loud
and i live off of you saying damn i made
a hundred bucks
i know that meat like it means something
i can't live a life where i'm like gary
v you made me lose a thousand dollars
this whole market collapsed
i can't live that life i'm done i don't
know it's so straight up
it's so straight up the only thing like
you said you got to do your homework you
got to know your stuff and my
brother like eats sleep sports and you
i was there and i was like dude there's
a bunch of tops chrome what what's up
he's like
buy all of it what
he's like get every single one
so i bought it put it on ebay i just
sent out this big fat box of this dude
and
we'll pocket 150 bucks and and there's
so many people watching right now
that like desperately truly could use an
extra 150 bucks a month truly
it's all out there it's all out there if
you're buying a target
at a walmart you just roll in there
every day everywhere chris if
if you really do your homework buying on
ebay because specific
cards yeah like the market is
super real that's where he's killing it
he's like i love the sports if you want
to get into it you got to know it but if
you don't love chris you don't love the
sports
no i was a fluke chris we're not doing
the sports
right
no i got you funny feeling that if you
went on [ __ ] ebay right now and
started
searching surfing gear and looked at
completed items
you could probably make a hundred
thousand a year flipping [ __ ]
surfing equipment buying it on ebay
getting it
retaking the photo and like do you know
what i mean
and by the way maybe you don't like that
either maybe you aren't like i'm
thinking about the
the home selling and the investment so
you do have that transactional flip in
you
yeah but you got to try other [ __ ] too
man
please 7 30 to 10 30 needs to be your
life please never let
7 30 to 10 30 not be you getting
educated on things you're interested in
somebody
go to youtube and just type in surfing
and i'm i'm focusing on surfing because
you gave me one data point
i'm trying to need other things yeah
yeah
all right bro one last thing i've got a
good friend that runs
um an entrepreneurial non-profit here if
i can just plug it real quick
and it's called venturelab.org and
they're on
facebook and i just think it's badass
because it's bringing entrepreneurialism
to the youth check it out pitchfest
right is that the right spelling yeah
yeah bro so
whatever it is for entrepreneurs i'm all
about
i gotta go i'm already one minute late i
love you pal i'm sorry
i'm gonna get to and the questions will
get to you on the next show dustin thank
you so much
everybody i hope you enjoyed the show i
felt like this set an interesting energy
like
i like this show i i i sometimes i like
this show because i think somebody
really clicked
today let me know if you clicked hit me
up on twitter garyvee
let me know if you clicked also make
sure you text me 212-931-5731
um that is that the right number doesn't
yeah good i've still got it uh and wine
text today please sign up if you buy
wine on the internet and you don't buy
it from my dad
that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] that is some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] there's no other way to
say it
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and today is a crazy
rose
hit me up on twitter garyvee and let me
know if something clicked for you today
and even better because i
because i'm going to be listening to
this meeting and i can kind of pay
attention
i'd love to know what click put hashtag
clickgaryvee
in there let me see love you twitch
family i love all of you in there
i see a lot of people ig ig i know a lot
of you watch
because we put the phone to it i see a
lot of people talking about the volume
being better on youtube
and twitch consider that switchover love
you always
see ya